[Musique]
elle a quitté la direction du Parti vert
du Canada en 2019 pour faire place à du
109 or trois ans plus tard voilà
qu'Elizabeth mai reprend la tête de sa
formation politique dans l'espoir de lui
redonner un lustre qui s'est
considérablement terni depuis son départ
le second règne qu'elle souhaite
partager avec son candidat Jonathan
penaud une façon pense-t-elle de faire
la transition vers la prochaine
génération comment espère-t-elle
convaincre les Canadiens de donner une
seconde chance à son parti j'ai posé la
question à Isabelle
Elisabeth met une nouvelle chef du Parti
vert c'est drôle de dire ça bonjour
Merci
pour cette opportunité nouvelle chef
parce que vous avez été réélu avec votre
chef adjoint il y a une semaine
maintenant de quoi aller le Parti vert
maintenant par rapport à ce qu'il était
en novembre 2019 quand vous l'avez
quitté je suis en novembre 2019 nous
sommes très forts nous avons élu toi
député dans les élections 2019
maintenant nous sommes dans une période
optimiste une période pour reconstruire
à sur le terrain pour notre base et avec
le but de lire plus de députés dont les
prochaines élections et peut-être avant
ça comment on fait pour reconstruire le
Parti vert aujourd'hui le parti a
traversé quand même une période
difficile très difficile
comment comment vous abordez la
reconstruction de ce parti la première
étape c'était les résultats de cette
course à la chefferie nous sommes deux
comme chef à mon partenaire plus jeune
il a 32 ans j'ai 68 ans alors à Johnson
et moi sont forts et optimistes beaucoup
d'énergie et aussi nous sommes en
position plus fort parce que maintenant
comme chef est aussi
député la voix des parties de verre dans
la chambre des communes sera plus fort
et avec Jonathan nous pouvons
partager le travail avec John qui veut
faire plus d'efforts dont l'intérieur du
pâté vert pour le reconstruire et moi je
vais concentrer sur le changement sur
les crises de changement climatique sur
l'effort de exiger
les choses qui on doit faire pour
protéger l'avenir donc quelqu'un
Parlement quelqu'un qui travaille le
côté politique est quelqu'un qui
travaille vos collègues Jonathan qui va
travailler essentiellement sur le
terrain pour rebâtir c'est ça
exactement bon il y a 8000 des 22000
membres qui ont voté au dernier
leadership c'est pas beaucoup ça
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il y a quelques règlements dans notre
crosse à la chefferie qui n'a pas fait
quelque chose que je veux faire pour
encourager la participation c'était un
course à la chef est très court nous
n'avons pas les adresses corielles de
tous les membres mais c'est vrai que il
y a aussi les gens qui ne sont pas
s'intéressent et c'est notre job
maintenant comme chef
tu fais l'effort pour encourager tout le
monde participer et il y a aussi les
anciens membres qui a la partie dont les
périodes de difficultés alors maintenant
je reviens je vais
rejoigner mon parti parce que nous
sommes dans un bon chemin maintenant je
sais que vous êtes une équipe et
Jonathan et votre chef adjoint pour
l'instant mais vous personnifiez le rôle
du chef comment vous faites pour dire
aux gens je suis la nouvelle image je
suis la reconstruction les gens ils
voient ils habitent comme la personne
qui a bâti une partie vers pas la
personne qui va pousser le Parti vert
vers l'avenir non je suis pas ici toute
seule et quand les gens partout aucun
rapport
non non
avec un approche nouvelle d'avoir une
crochet à Farid comme
les Québécois Québécois sont plus
familières avec cette concept à cause de
Québec solidaire mais nous sommes deux
comme eux
de partir
dans un justement de ce système de
cochef pourquoi vous pensez que c'est
important pour vous d'aller dans cette
direction là c'est un façon pour mettre
ce pied un système de transition
maintenant évidemment
plus jeunes que moi il est pour moi
l'avenir je veux travailler avec lui et
partager le travail mais aussi mettre ce
pied un système où la structure de
partie est plus au courant avec nos
valeurs
votre défi principal à partir de
maintenant vers la prochaine élection
quelle est-il et qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez comme résultat à la prochaine
avant les prochaines élections on doit
faire plus contre l'agence climatique ça
c'est la vie de JF on doit faire plus
moi-même avant les élections 2002 25
j'espère que nous serions un parti avec
plus de députés que maintenant plus de 2
avant les prochaines réactions dans la
chaîne à l'action nous sommes absolument
je suis certain que l'avenir pour partir
sera avec plus de 12 députés merci
beaucoup merci